hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within now
we got ruvik on our tail and we have no
idea how we're gonna predict him but all
we know is that he's going to be a dick
about everything and decide to pop up
whatever he feels like and poke me to
death was one of his long fingers so
they're in here now that's a cool thing
that happened whoo I forgot that I had
an axe I took a little bit of a breather
because it's very hot in this room right
now but if those guys wanna come tussle
with me they're gonna have a very big
problem
unless of course Rubik decide the show
it's faith and then I can start lisping
up a storm over here reveal my hidden
speech impediment trying to educate
yourself with books how dare you I'll
come ax you over goddamn why are there
so many okay so I'm gonna distract them
Oh everybody look quickly oh I should
have exploded them oh no wait oh they're
about to throw something at me that
seems like a bad situation being hang on
one second what what huh what is that oh
don't do that absolutely nothing give me
that hey you hey guess what ha
okay Alan's down now I'm gonna do this
one the old-fashioned way I haven't seen
these guys in a while so it's good to
know that they're still hanging around
I don't maybe if those guys with my
stupid grenade that did yeah
okay I got done exploded
give me your goop yes please give me a
green gel you don't know what happened
this is a total mystery here no you
didn't see nothing what do you think
you're doing what do you think you're
doing huh okay well if you're gonna be
like that then see those guys reason
they only take a few bullets even my
incredibly strategic plans that I spend
hours and hours planning strategically
when they go to waste I'm still able to
dispatch them with you no I Who am I
kidding maybe this is why I need to hide
now maybe I need to be able to hide from
Rubick Rubick room note I saw her there
again standing at the end of the hallway
long black hair beautiful was ever
streaked with moonlight highs dark pools
in a porcelain vase
she wore a favorite red dress like
crimson sunset like a streak of blood in
the waning light Laura of course you
couldn't be dead there well ok Rubik you
are a psychopath we all love you and I'd
really appreciate if you didn't trap me
in a corner somewhere and kill me get a
lot of stuff to do that thank you very
much oh he better not pop up is that
noise indicative of something happening
well I was a mistake apparently well
finally matches again I haven't had
matches in forever
oh you're a tough one oh no not so tough
anymore what did I drop I drop another
axe yes I did I could have dispatched
him I need to be more studious about my
scenarios kick it Albin don't go slow go
fast slow fast slow fast I don't know
don't get blowed up oh I can see where
the dial is okay let me try this oh that
was a lie
oh my god the dough where is he
Oh God what the Frick you son of a [ __ ]
you are gonna poke me to death Oh dare
are you well I don't sound good
sanctuary sanctuary I highly doubt this
is gonna give me sanctuary is it oh it's
locked
oh good oh good okay
oh good everything's fine now kaboom oh
this place looks nice then we got here
things I can destroy screw your
priceless artifacts talk today all right
what do you got for me yeah
thank you full up on those as a creepy
child you're a creepy lady that's a
broken vaz lay your head is right there
I got enough of those pick up the goop
yeah all the things covered in tarps I
do not trust it very much give it a go
gimme Dooku give me all to go that's
weird that don't let me get cornered
please I'm wondering because one on
route came last time there was this like
tone that raised up in a crescendo so
I'm gonna having a fun time over there
better not be at my expense so I'm
wondering if when that well you're back
you didn't see nothing I don't want to
try I don't want to do it here a
crescendo there's a sound of a roofie I
better save just just to be safe no no
here
Rubick thought that he could get me yeah
I forgot that you're pretty you're so
nice lady to me oh I'm so happy to have
you inside my brain you make me feel
like a thousand bucks I need ten
thousand for my next upgrade for the
normal harpin book zero ruvik around
you're a douche I know those in the
middle of getting the one upstairs but
I'm just gonna get this one now because
I can looking for blood
does anybody have a surplus of blood
they would like to donate is that a bomb
thought I heard a tick tick of a bomb
well here's another rule oka Pula
alrighty then ah okay I gotcha I gotcha
Manson music room note two worlds
separated by a jagged chasm above
faceless spectators mocking the tragedy
below the helpless victims losing
everything well I found the table lock
to that so that's a thing so I got to
find the bottom lock anybody what that
note was referring to was the painting
with the executioner standing up above
with the bags on their heads and I'm
assuming that the bottom half of the
painting is something that I'm gonna
need to find down the road where do I go
from here
obviously I need to find it's a noise is
something okay obviously I need to be
able to find the bottom lock but I also
might need to find the bottom of the
painting ha boesky ah here we go
well there's the bottom lock that made
it easy the old safe dial is marked with
the number 0 through 9 and there's the
bottom half of the painting well that
makes all right then why is she so close
he's about to get his head cut off
oh hello a weeping angel lady how are
you I don't have the combination to the
lock so I don't know if I need to find
that ha give me a key
hey I'm gonna I'm gonna axe your abdomen
and crotchal area give me a key lady ok
you have a nice day now what about this
lady oh oh that was Rubik portrait with
the bugs crawling out of it hey lady key
on the man
crunch stabber cousin of the butt
stabber ok so I found that you should be
able to go downstairs and for those
statues laughing at me did they come
alive
I'm gonna save no I'm not gonna say I'm
gonna say if now I'm not gonna say I
like to live on the edge I like to play
dangerously there's no way Rubick good
corner me and kill me there's just no
twas that door always there oh yeah I
already went here sorry I wasn't sure I
forgot forgive me Oh waiting first when
I put this in the thing and why is it so
full of blood
kachunk well I don't know this get out
of my face get out of my face I need to
find the combo I was pretty sure that's
what I needed to do but then I neglected
my own instinct and trusted my idiot
side which is what I've done through the
majority of this playthrough so I think
if I remember there was another way up
here where a pipe was leading which
would be where the blood was leading I
hear another monster somewhere hey hey
buddy buddy buddy hey hey anybody Rubick
stop me from going through here before
don't know if he's gonna do it again
hello
nice big alcoves too
okay that's a thing that's the thing
that's happening right now son of a
[ __ ]
got dead space flashback from something
grabbing my ankle got stupid trap is
that alright hopefully that gave me a
checkpoint of some sort what are we
getting
ah so ruling anybody seeing a roommate
creepy dude you know ah give me back
oh no extra crotch so hard she exploded
nothing in there it's a really squeaky
mouse but you health place Bob full up
too bad I need one that also got a full
like a big med kit ever I ever need that
one again but I need to make sure that I
use that in a very safe scenario hello
that's a secret passage
squeeze nothing okay
is there something oh I can hide under
the bed that would be very useful I'm
sure Rubik would be totally fooled
somehow it's gonna happen
what's all this then again who again yes
indeed please I shall do this more blood
for the blood machine is that all God
that eyes oh I see fear Center so I just
got it by pure luck before oh my god I
didn't know there was a total fear
center in the brain I guess I just got
totally lucky last time cuz I didn't
look at the thing
alright then good load up that good old
fear blood it's my baby let's get out of
here was that anatomical drawing of an
abdomen good okay
hey Rubik now would be a great time to
pop out if you only know i satisfy that
on your faces did you actually think
if you lock me away have we just ceased
to exist out of sight out of mind
you did you did didn't you
oh you're never out of my mind I hope
you're proud of yourselves
desi operatic you have won the totally
crazy or okay oh god oh god oh god damn
it
almost got cycled around all right I'm
about to jus here like a pro boss come
on state bounce you gonna jump into
those grinders over there sure will do
some good
get some color to your face earning
never do cuz I supposed to be something
that was supposed to collect because
didn't see ya rythmic no no really go
away Rubick no likes you
whoa hey whoa hey whoa whoa whoa
you're tolerable but the other whoa nice
dodge - got you chip I'm got your
everything [ __ ] give me that give me
that
Rubick one bye-bye so I guess I'll save
because I have it in a little bit so I
need to find a third place but I'm
assuming that's gonna be behind please
safe don't know why I got sassy on that
one okay something seems a little
strange there you've been expecting
thank you I
normally have let me just stop I got one
more key so let me make sure that I use
it properly all right yeah it's very
creepy around here I know I know I know
okay
eenie meenie miney moe catch tiger by
the you hey I should be whoa
7,000 hot damn damn okay can only Fame
so much excitement about what's going on
wait beloved son of wealthy haven't we
seen oh that was the Sun that's ruvik oh
okay that makes more sense now upgrade
please I don't even know if I you gonna
loosen my crossbow much I don't know why
I need it I mean I would upgrade my
pistol but yeah it's just it's only
useful against those little guys there's
no point in having it any other way
I want the harpoon 50,000 alicia does
240 240 percent now it's way better than
one who's doing before uh explosive bolt
no Nina
0:03 someone for ten seconds bow no no
I'm getting to the point where I don't
know what I should upgrade a good
upgrade melee damage okay oh I could
just upgrade this I've already upgraded
this I've upgraded this and Ari does a
lot of
it might be nice it's good critical
chance
I mean an ordinarily always kills an
enemy with a headshot anyway why did I
do that that was stupid stupidity looks
so stupid parade will be the leader I'll
just be marching down the street in my
underwear with no pants on screaming
about how that's the true way to play
games I do so crazy don't know well then
again I'm just rambling in my own room
just shouting away into a webcam and a
microphone at no-one around me everyone
in my neighbor's thinks I'm in totally
insane maybe I belong in this game cray
okay carrying on I'll just leave that
one where it lies okay so I gotta follow
where the last one I don't know remember
that oh I'm full up well I guess I could
switch out if that's the case because
then the other one could hold more yeah
I guess that would be good I mean I
technically still have the other gun
that would be able to hold it wait no
what do get to the other one
I want that oh I got you okay so I
technically have two shotguns here two
totally different shotguns
I don't know if one does more damage
than the other but we're just gonna go
have fun okay
so the last one is through this door
here but I don't have the combination I
don't know if I picked up something that
was supposed to tell me oh the paintings
there was two on the bottom how many
were on the top I have to go look again
all the paintings of course duh should
have been obvious where was that it was
over this way right man I don't know why
I didn't make that connection earlier
uh-huh top painting bottom painting too
on the bottom some number on the top it
was like eight or something eight people
now I'm more than that ten uno dos
today's four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven and I see those symbols in
the background over there so eleven and
all righty then
you could just jump you've jumped off a
higher places before there Sebastian
Booker DeWitt
oh right when I was running for my life
all right so that means that combination
will lead me to the last place of the
puzzle or I'll be able to drain the
blood out of somebody's brain after
stabbing it with a probe I'm very much
accustomed to given that I have great
practice in injecting my own brain with
strange substances I need to get my back
up because I want to start using it
again and last Rubik gonna say hi okay
this one needs to be okay that's the
same faces on the monster I guess that's
just what's inside the box
Oh
Oh God everyone has exploded face hello
Brian
oh you're only half of a brain
everything else in here I guess I'm not
good to it
before ruling decides to crash the party
Oh Hope Center I really don't think
anything's you know the Hope Center Oh
what the hell that's exactly where it's
supposed to be right oh it's an exploded
view okay sorry it's an exploded view
thought that was where it was my bad
what what the poop what the poopy poop
the same oh no that's perseverance oh I
was looking at the wrong thing oh I
thought the hope the little pin there
made me think that that was drawing an
arrow to okay so sorry I'm dumb I will
admit that's not the Hope Center you all
right there buddy you want some water
you look good it's good all right then
whatever
everything was normal in here that's why
all the save icons have been pins in the
brain and why would they
as the hospital been doing anything
worthy come donation the Victoriano
family has always been a generous
contributor we're your parents I came to
inform you with assistance materials
your research will very quickly
disintegrate me okay so this is really
weird because oh those goop it up the
whole time we're actually in rubik's
brain right now and i'm assuming that's
why Rubik is not too happy with that and
is therefore blowing everything up
inside of me and making that suddenly
outside of me she's not too happy with
us being in this brain i know i know i'm
gonna save over annoy a check point was
this reached when i did that i should be
fine oh it's a big brain I didn't notice
that the gears on the door we're a big
brain so I'm still curious what role
well that's happened all the time why
are you surprised now Booker Sebastian
I'm so curious to see what Leslie's
[Music]
slice clean all the way you know cure
for what I'm going to do to you peel or
steamed skin thoughts from the minds
Rubick
hi I'll be down in just a little bit no
no no no no oh
follow the bug so this'll be good okay
oh god bugs more bugs Oh more bugs I was
hoping you know I didn't want to wish no
wishing upon a star for more bugs all
right bye bye Rubik you're gonna play a
game with me huh
well I got the strength of will of 10
men probably not so long Sebastian as
bunkers have alcohol and on the trees
fine
oh good its Silent Hill PT
I really I really oh they don't look
good that's a big something where'd you
go
I said no hey now you're an ulcer just
get you on go away it is silent PT loop
this over and over in half oh this is
bad
oh boy it is very bad ain't it so I
gotta carefully navigate all this
[ __ ] is that what you're saying huh
oh boy I miss some green goop
damn it was probably a 5,000 er probably
not yi yi dish ously what it's not like
those cables are gonna snap
well maybe the cables would trigger the
ceiling I guess I thought it was on a
timer that meant that I could have gone
back at any point gotten what I needed
but I whoa lady no you do not don't
Oh Oh mr. bug man come on now with this
printed by Sprint I'll take that oh I
want a wrong way oh god what am i doing
what am i doing why did I go that way oh
I gotta not run out of sprint oh I am Oh
Oh what was I supposed to do
okay about me sometimes we a lot a lot
okay so what am I supposed to do here
that's full okay hi al bugs a lot of
bugs my pistol because I'm sure it's
what I'm gonna need
god dammit I thought I could go oh god
oh god I'm gonna blow you still you
ready great for some [ __ ]
okay that didn't work that didn't do
nothing oh god oh god that hurts
okay mistake
get out of here you psycho cray way from
the mannequin heads
I don't know face ogres an alien oh good
back here again good down [ __ ]
I'm sorry cover Victor Rhonda Victoriano
estate okay more goop 500 totally worth
all that why did I just reach out and
touch the wall no idea oh good
this is pretty
you look old and dignified are you about
to murder someone how good okay why was
I let here I have no idea it's in Rubik
mind I know how old Rubik is some of
these memories seem like they're from
like the colonial times this is so
pretty
I'm gonna field of daisies almost makes
me forget about the nightmare that just
happened with mannequin heads I knew it
was coming
it's reason the loading screen was there
it had to be there
is there any secret goodies that I need
what is that oh tiny jar would have been
very easy to overlook too bad it was
almost useless for me to get that a
shock bolt mana collected so many these
harpoons I didn't even know that I would
need them and then I ran out immediately
because they just spammed him all over
the place need to be conservative about
it oh and apparently I never addressed
this but apparently there are plenty of
other opportunities for me to get the
crossbow but I just didn't find him
which is weird cuz I could have sworn
that I found every single silver case I
ever found and I opened it Laura
oh it's Rubik sister that's right black
hair that's right no you're here I can
hear you breathing Wow Rubick some kind
of dumb dumb
oh is he blind oh is Rubik blind
think they can buy up all our land but
if they're the money show no really all
these cards well I mean alright then
is murder necessary oh that's how he got
scarred burned Oh Oh plop okay he's not
blind
hey I think there's kids in there I
didn't hear anything yeah it seems like
the proper way to go about things such
good neighbors whoa I did not need to be
in here for this Oh Reuben
[ __ ]
boy that's a new new idea okay so I need
to get out the same way that she pushed
her brother to get out oh do I go up
there no that looks deadly
Oh ladder ladder ladder get it go on
jump for it child you got a job for it
oh those that I didn't even see this
alright then crank it up I don't know
what I'm cranking but I'm gonna crank it
oh I see it's gonna be able to get me up
to the lab what bullets I need you to
see those give me up there alright go go
oh okay so I need to go okay well I was
just thinking about it had to die oh
come on what the poop what the poopy
poop whole place burned down I can't
even do nothing
what's this do
oh I wasn't doing it right anyway I'm
gonna burn to death soon it's gonna be
so much fun cranking it crank crank that
yank
crank you good like you knew that you
could
okay awfully convenient that whatever
the hell this thing is right here I'm
not familiar with farming equipment so I
have no idea anything else I need in my
extreme rush to get out of here oh well
alright then are those actually bugs are
they just droplets of blood I'm kind of
inclined to think of their blood now
okay so what do I do about this what am
I supposed to do about this whoa hey
don't you get that away from me oh hi
whoa Nelly someone is like that
someone don't like me killing their
minions
oh this guy's bit tougher they got rods
in their heads making me miss huh no I
said no no to usurp Ernie oh I'll take
your AMRO you're not dead are you know
whoa God okay okay okay let's let's take
a step back here as I read
this is not the room oh yes it is whoa
got that guy whoa wait whoa eh whoa oh
the face
oh no no no no no get out of here get
out of here I saw a medkit on the ground
I need to use one of these right about
now right about now folks your brother
yeah oh my god that's calamitous what's
over okay
ow poor girl
is he using me to get to the memory of
his sister oh no
who me
oh goody knows inevitable anyway oh hi
again well thanks for the little trip
down memory lane Rubik that a much
appreciated I can't turn around I can't
move my mouse other than forward you've
got to keep your strength up okay
[Music]
Beatrice was I supposed to listen more
to that conversation I didn't know it
was gonna end when I am in there
alrighty then it's back there and I'm
gonna be through there in just a second
nope kink oh ok so I have no choice but
to pass through this little alcove into
who knows where
Oh at the end of the chapter I see it a
chapter good job Rubick showing me the
inside of your mind you're a welcome
accept and moving on to the next chapter
it's fun I've had a good time playing
this game I gotta admit it was like
there was some ups and down moments your
mannequin yes it was some up and down
moments in the beginning but right now
I'm actually in a really good groove
with the game I mean I like the story I
like the mystery too and I like the
aspect that you know I like the inside
the mind everything can change and
everything is very fluid in it pulls off
that quite well I mean it looks good
I've improved the graphics with flame
letter boxing
moving the letterboxing getting it to 60
frames a second you know it looks really
good a lot better than it did there's so
much detail in the game oh and there's
like Ruben does he mean ruvik they
received as they themselves gave and
they served a higher purpose they
brother of my research this was not mere
research the things the papers say were
talking to those people those traps
these vermin
these microbes they're mine to do with
as I please
but you aren't correctly this was not
mere research I'm close to perfection
this is abhorrent this is my will okay
then Ruby over there is a little bit
controlling anyway what I'm saying is
that this game is really cool and it has
some general creep factor to it my
children have been taken from me was it
my fate was it fate was it something he
did surely not my perfect son it was
that fire it ruined everything took
everything the children are not the same
and neither is Ernesto he said he was
taking care of them that they were safe
but now he says there's gone how could
that be a mother would know such a thing
I still hear my dollar and darling boy's
voice his laughter and always from the
basement it cannot be a mother needs her
children whose mama is that Rubik mama
so like there's some general creep
factor too I mean it is mostly action
but at the same time it surprises me
like because I'm expecting it to just be
mostly sad no so I'm expecting it to be
mostly straight of action when these
like periods like really
creepiness happen yeah your head still
on your shoulders be thankful for that
it really does surprise me and I gotta
say I really liked this game I'm really
getting into it I mean as with any game
when I first started I have no idea it
was one guy next door yeah who is that
guy it was Lesley before hey buddy I'm
trying to sleep over here get some peace
and rest who's over there huh anybody in
there Oh next door do you have any idea
why this world is the way it is now what
who are you
hate hate Rubik hate the man's consumed
by it he wants out wants to get his
revenge he wants back what he feels the
world took from him it's not like he
could actually get that it's not like he
could actually get that this world
exists as long as he does you heard
something just not yes thank you nurse
for creeping up on me again and being a
general weirdo so how have things been
inside my brain been comfortable okay so
I collected all these things oh god I I
remember this this painting that's where
the mannequin was standing in front of I
don't know if I got another key who's
gonna save and see what happens from
then on out and there's got to be
something else in here that I need to
find I guess maybe maybe maybe not I
have no idea um it doesn't hurt to
explore a little bit I might be able to
pull from some of the stash that I
didn't collect all the way and also I've
been getting in more pieces of the map
Wow come on all right
I'm never gonna be able to fill that
whole thing out table no clues as to
where we are in here
I have no keys everything is empty empty
empty empty empty empty and what are you
ooh I did not know that I had lightning
bolts over there I hear something
somebody hears something I really don't
know if that's gonna be the last of the
mannequin face that was really cool by
the way I was kind of caught in the
middle of it like in the full-on creep
factor but the mannequin thing like I
don't even know if that's the only
mannequin thing but that was really cool
like I gotta admit I love the
mind-bending aspect of this game I love
how everything shifts and changes and
moves it's very fluid it keeps
everything interesting like the setting
may be same in some areas but
everything's so so so varied and
interesting and is cool and I love it
it's really really really cool people
can say whatever they want about being a
generic shooter but I think that's like
a vehicle for the world that we are in
oh god I just had to say something
no no I just had to say something good
damn it
all right Han over here first that looks
like a death trap
oh no okay okay now don't do that to me
okay okey - too bad I just went back I'm
not gonna go in right away I'll just use
a key later so should I be worried about
that should I be worried I'm worried
who's worried do I look worried
well sorry there did not mean to disturb
you
okay then so this is the hall of fun oh
there are the heads again good old heads
how you doing oh yeah the checkpoint we
here what's in there now okay it's just
normal monsters who since the normal zom
zoms nothing for me to worry about I
didn't even notice the trap was there
good thing I did okay I cannot see
anything oh now I can whoa hey you
should look right about here hey no
don't do whatever you're doing right
there is stupid idiot yeah yeah yeah
weird huh yes so weird
whatever that may or may not have been
what did I do
[Music]
god damn booth that thing
it got me stuck on the it's stuck on the
geometry I couldn't get around it whoa
whoa
it is the carnival fun whoa stay down
buddy oh my goodness I did not know that
we're gonna have an awesome time here
look at that that's so cool that's so
cool what kind of demented mind came up
with that device whoa okay then I don't
know what that was all about
whoo hey I want to take you on a magic
carpet ride hey come over here I need to
speak with you about something
lady look up this makes my life a lot
easier
oh why did she have spikes all over
where those are knitting needles who's
she in a horrible knitting accident gone
wrong accident gone wrong yes of course
of course who's doing that who's
shooting okay
who the hell it's all up there well you
gave away your position now I've got two
better sniping skills than you did my
friend also you got a really bright
light on you um okay yeah
you make my life so easy pop your head
up Hey
okey-dokey then little kid just having a
fun time at the carnival
no one's gonna mind me telling all the
other patrons say some cables going up
this way something important happening
well that guy's big too bad he's not too
big for a sniper rifle through the face
ooh if I can get that bottle I might be
able to distract him and then kill him
with expeditious force which I have not
been all this doing never mind
for all my normal plans out the window
it's gonna shoot him really hard
bonk hey buddy Oh
what you took more than once nice well
whoops okay that guy needs to be burned
by you God okay I got a Burnie for you
Oh maybe you were dead never mind is too
sniper rifles I think three actually
maybe that'll actually take care you all
right so that's that I'm gonna collect
the last bullet that was actually down
here just so I can not waste bullets
because sniper rifle bullets don't come
around all the time
might need them everyone soil if I could
just stop getting damaged through
stupidity
I would be very happy oh I wasn't done
gonna oh yes please take your time not
like everything's horrible actually it's
kind of the nicest place we've been so
far it's a carnival now they're clown
masks finally makes sense what I really
wonder is if the people that I'm killing
here like these people are people that
are also in this place but they've lost
their minds is that what's going on here
cause if it is that's pretty morbid cuz
then I'm just killing everybody else in
here or maybe they'll wake up and why
the happy fun time together
kaboom oh I could have just blew that up
why didn't I I don't think I didn't see
it what is that battery pack this large
portable storage cell can be used to get
electrical equipment working in an
emergency handy I'm just gonna shoot
lightning at it till it works that's
good for electronics all right
I believe it it's in the ravings of a
madman why not is that a sniper is that
just a light pass is a light
about you yeah the light okay fine
whoa that's not alike well really Oh Oh
Oh mr. ducky ducking tainha goodbye
thank you all right I don't get over
there I'll get over there I need to hop
onto one of those it wasn't a way around
I don't think unless that wasn't
supposed to come up here of course I was
supposed to come up here there was no
other way to go
that's it wasn't huh although I guess I
didn't check back downstairs might have
been something else they're so awfully
suspicious I mean I think I just need
you to come up there just so I can get
that item make sure that I can get
electronics to work but I don't even
know where the hell that is
I don't think it's an item that I can
use on demand I think it has to be very
situation specific though
[Music]
that's mildly terrifying oh hi come on
oh you're smart oh not that smart though
[Music]
what else we get guy thing for me no way
girl there's someone in here right
hey friend piss sold for you cheap and I
get a lot of pistol bullets and I don't
get a chance to use it as much nope is
enough truth gotcha
have fun in death wherever the Dead
going a brain of a madman alright I'll
save it I probably won't take that much
damage
markiplier says totally not inciting the
wrath of every whatever you know what I
meant
bad things are gonna happen now that I
said that once gana could have just shot
that but did not see it of Oscar yeah oh
I should use my Poon's more I thought
I'd wait oh I did use my Poon's back in
the back another thing over there
electricity well that didn't seem like
it should have done that
oh that's Andy is it gonna run out do I
have to go back you gotta go back Oh
whoosh don't get up don't get up yo oh
god if you would have gotten up write
that in there why did that blow up on
the ground or something
I need that med kit now but I can't do
it because I'm crouched okay safe and
sound let's use this and get really
really crunk why did I punch myself it
was like the stupidest thing I've done
aah
and then did this like do the syringe in
my arm I punched myself really hard why
ow how we kapowee that poit
okay I'm better I'm I'm over it I think
hello someone having a fun time in there
Howie
that really hurt oh man okay anyway in
the land of being normal and not being
weird on camera in front of thousands
literally hundreds of thousands do you
need to be burned do you need to be
burned do any of you need to be burned
is this a pile of bodies whoa [ __ ]
the [ __ ] and what pray tell was that it
looked big was it that thing I was
running away from before been okay now
so why do I have an extremely bad
feeling about that an eyeball
oh god that's an eyeball isn't it yeah
yeah that's an eyeball and that's a face
oh that's not a face I thought it was a
face good that makes it so much better
now that everything's not totally crazy
so what the hell was that thing
I'm not gonna need to use the
electricity is that why they're giving
me one cuz I'm gonna need to stun it
turn out the light be a little stealthy
about this
I'm quiet I'm quiet I'm so salty don't
do that okay I got checkpoint which
means they're gonna kill me soon good
that looks deathly I want that I want
that so badly I'm gonna get it how about
getting uh oh well that's not good I'm
in trouble aren't I
I'll get out of here well that was just
in time huh
good luck that out better oh no oh no oh
no I wanted that it's not gonna come
back in is it diam it damn it damn it
damn it I didn't know I didn't know that
I couldn't melee the cross which I
should know I should have shot it got in
and out well that was my bad that cost
me I should just let her kill me that
way I could have gone back and do it
again but I'm a dumb-dumb I'm a
dumb-dumb I don't know no better I won't
be able to do nothing can I shoot that
three please tell me I can hey bro
you should go right yeah oh my gosh
whoa did that get you
I don't think that got you all the way
okay
bonk oh come here I need to shoot your
nan there we go okay yes on the critical
hits this is what I like for one more
where else Lawson join the party it's
called the brains of the walls oh wait
sorry
sorry hello over there sorry I missed
I'm gonna get you eventually don't worry
sorry sorry I'm not giving you the
treatment you deserve any bullets over
here really is some bullets eat some
bullets hey friend you don't look so
good one mole left let me oh that didn't
do nothing all right thought we were
gonna do that fun you guys made it offer
hey you want a bottle in the face it is
a party wouldn't be no party without
some booze hey friend oh come on
with this burn up because I feel like it
all right you're burnin goody goody
gumdrops
this whole combat thing sure is getting
easy for me maybe because I'm so
incredibly skilled or some other reason
no it's gotta be that it must be there's
no other possible solution okay
so I think there was another way to go
here
you son of a [ __ ] is it that don't even
give me no warning no more it just blows
up but as you can see Sebastian is such
a freakin badass doesn't even faze him
anymore and they start using my crossbow
bolts also I've plenty of grenades so I
haven't been using them either where's
this douchery atleast Jojo isn't
cramping my style anymore
I don't even know where Jojo went guys
glass is back and then he left me there
gonna be a save point any time soon
good thing I use my crossbow like an axe
sure that's good for the movie making
mechanisms why did it get subtly more
red okay never mind
all right then sounds of nightmare who
sounds a nightmare thought make a good
band name oh that's what's bad okay
I was wondering what's bad that's right
there
where's that you want to facehole
shotgun can't see anything by bad you
can't see nothing
yeah yeah I got a bad feeling about this
I got a bottle perfect exactly what I
need to survive sniper rifles actually
that is good all right what are you
loading me up for checkpoint what are
you loading me up for oh boy whoa
I am very stupid okay oh I got it okay
this is why I picked this up gray what
did that I don't think that's what I
wanted it to do
oh good for me that's a bad sound ain't
it Oh am I in a heater now they turn on
an industrial heater is that what I did
oh boy
oh hi howdy howdy howdy oh god oh god oh
god oh god no you do not you fall down
you burn up you burn up you burn up okay
you just blow up okay now I'm gonna burn
you too can't waste no nothin
reload reload reload we got time and
only turned on the heaters
Sebastian any worried about a little
sweat
well okay that's all nice I think your
head will part I don't thinking into
burner off me up okay well yeah well
good I've got now chaos course of course
with this thing in the panic moments I
can't hit my goddamn target hey [ __ ]
that's the big I was very worried about
hey hey whoa hey whoa whoa
[Music]
Watson okay that gay friends
those supposedly does more damage oh how
much I need to do excuse me excuse me
Oh hundred very useful we're gonna say I
need to kill this guy before I move on
well god damn it
Oh God
I'm gonna die do I need to shoot that
pulsating tumor on your back okay
win this engagement Emma oh I got ya I
got ya I didn't need to shoot the tumor
on your back okay all right we're good
to go
I think oh no maybe
tear chunk okey-dokey then
okay
you know oh okay I see okay I kind of
done that who's that a heat press quite
literally okay please run do I have a
health kid I don't know if I do i do yes
please thank you very good I'm not gonna
hit my own arm again this time get out
of here now so I'm assuming I need to go
under those I want to go to okay yeah
I'm not going for it I know there's
brain juice down there but I'm not gonna
risk it come too far not gonna die now
it says the idea this fall one harp and
left full shotgun okay let's roll with
that see what that I can do for me
let's just Sue's a backup picture that's
full
box please that for a second there that
sounded like from dead space Issac
Clarke's girlfriends scream after she's
telling everyone to make her whole
that's a good question
why didn't you ask it about everything
else it sounds like another scrapy guy
that's a piece of a map was that doing
here yeah good for me examine you mean
examine as in jump right in is that what
you meant cuz that's what you did let's
actually let's actually not assume that
I can sneak around here
come on okay you're hitting everything
but your target they're good actually
let me craft up a bit more plain-jane
agony bullets yeah let's go full why not
I also got some explosives for backup
but I don't want to use those right away
just in case I'm awful with them you're
not just a thing oh you got it quick
whoa wait oh god why oh that fair oh
that is not fair what the hell are you
doing what the hell are you doing oh
whoa whoa good lordy Lou are you trying
to pull oh how am I supposed to how am I
supposed to do this so I got a dice I'm
on the right side oh god I'm so dead
it's not fair it's unfair
oh god I'm so dead let me use my grenade
grenade grenade grenade grenade put it
in the four slot now put it in the two
slot
oh god this in the four [ __ ] we're good
well good was that tip to me I was
already dead I'll sum over my time I
would like a save point here cuz our I
forgot I picked up one of these oh is it
god damn nightmare
okay let's approach this a little more a
little more better Lee what I'm gonna do
is if I have a frizzy one I do I have
exactly one frizzy one I'm gonna use
that I can actually craft more frizzy
ones because I want to trap them and
then I can shoot them in their back it's
the idea anyway cuz I believe that's
what the strategy is going to be yes
alright it's costly need to do it okay
good enough for me hey buddy Oh what are
you duck
okay curium yes both of them whoa okay
oh you piece of [ __ ] god damn it you
piece of [ __ ]
you piece okay here we go this is gonna
be going what the Frick wire to frozen
[Music]
[Applause]
absolutely not sane okay all right it's
impossible all right so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna end the episode here and
I'm gonna finish this in another episode
because I'm already over an hour and I
don't want to go too far over an hour
more for me to do ask her and I'll
finishes whatever I'll finish it screw
it screw it my original plan was good
but I didn't have enough ammo to do
anything about it how do I do this how
do I do this how do I do
how can I do it why can't I do they need
I need so much more everything so much
more everything
wish I didn't have to waste time and
energy on this [ __ ] blah blah be a
son-of-a-bitch
okay here we go not that one whoa did
they hit each other I think they did
[Music]
okay oh gods writing your cross
everybody nice crotch shot did you like
that free last one of that damn it
okay this down get out of that corner
please thank you okay what do i do what
do i do do i do please do nothing
oh god why use ooh oh boy oh boy oh boy
okay crawl get around and crawl under it
whatever you have to do oh god got some
extra bullets whose move on who you see
thank you explode nice that good for me
this shoot
you didn't tell me you can do that one
of them down one of them down one of
them down
okay how about another one for you sir
he's done his son his son son yes I did
it I did it I did it I did it
3,000 I'll take it I did it I did it
okay now taking any chances
well bombs no bombs no bombs where's
that bomb that blew me up before unless
my arrow happened to compound it and
blow him up as well I think that's what
I okay so now that that crisis is over
hopefully there's gonna be the end of
something soon oh there's more shotgun
shells in here house really difficult
I'll limit those right challenging that
was but I persevered with skill
oh this would be stressful if there was
something chasing
sounds like the quake 3 arena getting
hit set by a demos don't tell me there's
another one I don't want to hear nothing
about there being another one right here
I'm not up for dealing with it had a lot
of crap happening to me all I see is
whoa please let there be a save some
time soon I want to say please give me a
save please
[Applause]
blowing I like it don't
oh come on with this [ __ ] okay well
well then well then do you want to give
me a save world's longest episode ever
longest episode of a let's play ever
right here now like it's not too big of
a deal Oh what
Oh
[Music]
that's normal summer in this world don't
know what you're trying to surprise me
with those who seek to consume me there
are in the darkness but only the
Phantom's of my mind to come from me to
taunt me
I nearly lost myself completely okay
okay then you do that Reuben Rubick I'm
gonna save journalist Sebastian
Castellanos
I've watched friends and colleagues die
before part of the job I've taken that's
never easy
but nothing can compare to losing your
own child I die a million times over to
prevent it but I can't I felt so
helpless when they lowered that tiny
coffin into the ground the pain is
unbearable I know I shouldn't but
drinking is the only thing to lets me
sleep for the last few weeks I'm worried
about Meera this has been extremely hard
on her and her way of handling it has
been unnerving she wants to be alone has
taken up to staying up all night says
she's going doing work to keep her mind
off the tragedy but she keeps seems to
be closing yourself off to the world
I know attends a band when a couple
loses a child and I hope that we're
strong enough to avoid it sad creepy and
sad that's what this game is but the
title the evil within makes a lot of
sense please just let me save let me
save
have you forgotten something no thank
you I just want to save right now cuz I
gotta end this episode here so anyway
thanks a long episode hope you guys
enjoyed it though thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done in the past
there's a lot of them and as always I
will see you in the next video
one thing's gonna happen
[Music]